[Arabic recitation]
regarding mud.
Then we're going to go into
then then the author is going to head
into the chapters regarding bathing.
And another chapter that is often
overlooked by many brothers and that is
the issue of
menration and postpartum.
And the reason I say it's overlooked by
many brothers is obvious.
Many brothers don't have menration or
postpartum. However,
we are surrounded by women. Women that
need us and need our guidance and
knowledge.
Our mothers, our sisters, our daughters,
not one of us except that he is a son.
He is a brother. Many of us, he is a
father to daughters. And it's your
responsibility to learn these
rulings and to teach them to those
around you. So we will discuss that.
Coming soon is the issue which is a real
can of worms often times which is
wiping over the footwear.
Usually people have a lot of questions
about that. It's not difficult. It's not
complicated. If you pay attention to the
beginning principles that we lay down,
the rest will be easy inshallah.
The author
finishes up the chapters regarding mudoo
discussing the instances in which it is
preferred that a person make wudoo. He's
mentioned and list listed a number of
things which we have discussed in detail
that it is
it is preferred it is encouraged that a
person make wool for the occasion of any
remembrance of Allah
for the occasion of sleep.
If a person is in a state of janaba,
if they wish to eat or drink or sleep,
or if they wish to
continue or have relations again without
bathing.
Another time in which it is preferred
that a person make wool is before
bathing. And we mentioned this and this
will become more detailed in the chapter
regarding alul inshallah in in a couple
chapters.
One that is often overlooked and
honestly very much so a forgotten
sunnah.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
tells us in Muslim
Wasam.
[Silence]
He says, "Whoever breathes life into a
sunnah that is
dead prior, a sunnah that's been
forgotten by people. How do sunnah
become forgotten? They are forgotten.
The first step towards forgetting a
sunnah of our prophet sallall.aii
wasallam is not implementing it, not
putting it into action. If I don't do
it, but I'm expecting you guys to do it
and you guys don't do it cuz you're
expecting me to do it. And we continue
this, what happens? It's very easy
for a generation to forget an a sunnah
entire communities to not be
implementing
broad sides and aspects of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam sunnah.
This is the danger. This is the fear.
This is why we say if you ever hear a
sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam
never
completely leave it off ever.
Don't have the
the idea of all or none, 100% or 0%. No.
If you hear of a sunnah, implement it.
Even if only 10%.
Even if only 5%.
Never
have a relationship with any sunnah of
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. No
matter how big or small
never have a relationship of zero
implementation with any sunnah of his
sunnah.
He deserves better and you deserve
better and your children deserve better.
This is a gift. Never turn away from the
prophet.
[Silence]
Allah says, "Oh you who have believed,
obey obey Allah and his messenger and
never turn away from him whilst you can
hear that he is calling you. So never
have a relationship to his sunnah
of any of his sunnah with 0%
implementation
implement it even if only 10% of your
life even if only 5% of your life we can
work on increasing it
this is how a sunnah dies now I'm going
to mention to you one of these sunn that
is all but dead I'm sure that many of us
have never heard of this sunnah before
and there will be many more it that
will come.
Making
after eating something that has been
licked by flames directly.
eating any food
that has been directly
roasted on a fire meaning there's no
pan there's no right between it and the
flame.
This is a food whether it's meat usually
it's meat but it could be other things
as well that is directly
cooked on an open flame
directly
licked by the by the flame.
It is the sunnah to make woo after
eating such a
food. So for instance, anything that is
grilled directly essentially, right?
That's what that translates to.
you know how when when you have a
barbecue or a grill and you take some
vegetables and you put them on the grill
and you take some meat and you put it on
the grill and then the flames come up
and they touch the food directly. It
is the sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam to make wudoo after
eating a food that has been directly
touched by fire.
I I would wager if I was a betting man
that many of us have never heard of this
before. And I would wager that you've
never seen someone make wubul for the
occasion of eating something this.
And that's what a forgotten sunnah is,
right? That's what a forgotten sunnah
is.
[Silence]
Muslim.
We
and
to sleep.
[Silence]
All
and so it is the sunnah to make wuboo
after eating anything that has been
touched directly by an open flame.
Due to the narration of the of
who narrates to us, I heard the
messenger of Allah.
Wasam say, "Make wool after eating what
has been cooked on an open flame." I
think that's pretty clear, right? Make
woo after eating anything that has been
cooked on an open flame. This narration
has been collected by Muslim.
Now we know that it is mustab because
just that at its face means that it's
obligatory. If he commands something,
it's obligatory.
However, we have instances of him eating
a eating something that was cooked on an
open flame and not make for doing it. So
we know that even though that was not
the majority of his sunnah however there
are instances which means that this is
something that is highly encouraged and
a person may say well what's the
point of that why why make wool
for eating something that has been
directly cooked on an open flame
the believer's arch enemy is fire.
The believer's arch enemy is fire. The
prophet sallall.aii wasallam
was told about a family in Medina.
Their house burned down while they were
inside and it killed them.
And when he was told about this, he
said,
because they left a little bit of fire,
you know, a little flame probably for
the kids, you know, a nightlight or
it was cold, so they wanted to leave a
little a little flame there, right? Then
it spread.
a a mouse came in there or a rat came
in there or something knocked it over, a
child or a a cat or a dog or something.
It burned the house down while they were
sleeping. And so the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam commented and
said, "The fire is your enemy."
As an enemy is, it's constantly trying
to get at you. It's constantly trying to
escape you.
He says, "So if you sleep,
put the fire out before you go to sleep.
It's not permissible to sleep with an
open flame."
And so the fire is a person's enemy. And
so part of that is that I'm not going to
I'm not going to take something that was
directly touched by my enemy without
washing myself. This is the ideology.
And so the point is is that one of the
sunnah is to make wudoo
after eating something that has been
touched by an open flame. You're
welcome. There's a new sunnah that I'm
sure many of us have never heard. You
can start doing it today. Today. You can
start today.
eat steaks tonight. Sticks. All right.
[Arabic recitation]